[Musique]
après les idées cadeaux les idées de
sorties à présent dans ce journal
pendant les vacances de noël c'est bien
sûr l'occasion de passer du temps en
famille à la maison ou lors de sorties
et en cette année les villes se sont
passé le mot puisque le rendez vous les
rendez vous sont très cinéphile mélanie
pokémon soir ça pour votre pour vos
idées de sorties vous nous faites ce
voyage et au sein du septième art
justement c'est bien ça grégory les fans
de cinéma vont être ravis y est tout
particulièrement les amoureux de star
wars les quais sous bois nous rendent
hommage aux 40 ans de la saga de george
lucas s'est surtout aux passionnés parce
que tous les objets et jouets que vous
pourrez découvrir leur appartiennent
elle est à découvrir jusqu'au 12 janvier
à l'espace philippe noiret l'idée
c'était qu'on fasse une exposition qui
soit à la fois participative donc
c'était un appel à la fois des
collectionneurs privés mais aussi des
gens qui pouvaient apporter leurs objets
qu'il voulait exposer donc c'était là la
première étape
et puis ensuite qu'elle soit interactif
comme star wars que l'on retrouve aussi
du côté de versailles les lego
investissent l'espace richaud imaginez
grégory des milliers de petites briques
en plastique pour revivre les plus
grandes scènes du cinéma l'an bien sûr
vous l'avais dit la star wars du roma
les adhérents de l'association brésil
ils y ont réfléchi pendant un an leur
travail est composé de près de 300 mille
pièces mais on peut passer de longues
minutes à chercher maître yoda luke
skywalker ou encore dark vador il n'y a
pas que star wars puisqu'on va pouvoir
reconnaître batman les visiteurs astérix
mission cléopâtre
les premiers visiteurs ne savait plus
trop où donner de la tête j'aime bien
celle d'harry potter est celle de star
wars
génial on a vraiment envie d'avoir ces
légaux et de les construire
y'a plein de créativité c'est très beau
même beaucoup ça me donnait envie de
construire des petits ego et ça m'a mis
plein d'idées à des constructions alors
signer en brique est à découvrir à
l'espace richaud de versailles c'est
jusqu'au 25 janvier
je vais pas vous grégory mais moi ça m'a
donné envie de revoir quelques
films-cultes quand même effectivement
guerre civile a dit dans quelques
instants on vous retrouve aux manettes
de votre émission le 7-8 loisirs avec
d'autres idées de sorties en ces
vacances de noël